어 안녕하세요. 저희가 차로
이동하면서 어 상권을 좀 소개하는
코너를 좀 만들었는데 오늘 첫 번째로
갈 곳은 성수동입니다. 그래서 지금
여기 젠틀 몬스터 4혹 앞에 와
있습니다. 2021년도에 56억
정도에 샀더라고요. 그래서 건물을 사
가지고 리모델링을 했거든요. 비용
들여서 리모델링을 했는데 그걸 철거한
다음에 어 이렇게 만들어 놨습니다.
뭔가 관광 명소가 된 거 같습니다.요
땅이 한 2018년 19년도에 두
필지를 산 거거든요. 그래서 그때
당시에 굉장히 큰 공장이었는데 어
그거를 사 가지고 240억 원대 하나
사고 260억 원대 하나 사 가지고
이렇게 건물 올렸습니다. 그래서 제가
대출 받은 금액을 보니까 한 1억을
대출을 했더라고요. 딱 매입
비용으로도 쓰고 공사비로도 좀 사용한
거 같습니다. 이거 생기면서
이쪽으로도 유동인과 많이 오기
시작했어요. 사실 여기까진 사람들이
많이 없었거든요. 근데 여기 보시면
아시겠지만 지금 관광객들도 많이 오고
이쪽으로 사람들이 좀 오기
시작했습니다. 원래 연무장길은서
연무장길이 제일 좋았어요. 그래서 막
기사 나갔던 뭐 2억 대다 3억에
팔렸다 그게 다서 연무장길에 있었는데
어 최근에 이제 동 연무장길까지
확산되면서 거기에 최근에 3억 원에
팔린게 있습니다. 되게 빠른 속도로
같이 따라와서 가격이 오르고 있고
그리고 여기 밑에 쪽까지도 상권이
지금 이어지려고 하고 있어요. 그래서
만약에 지금 빌딩 이쪽 투자를 좀
계획 중이다라고 하면은 여기 지금
밑에 쪽도 한번 좀 보시면 좋을 거
같아요. 여기까지 확장이 될 거
같습니다. 여기 진짜 사람이
없었거든요. 근데 저기 이제
젠틀몬스터 사혹 생기면서 여기 이제
유동인 거 많이 생겨 놨습니다.
그리고 저는 좀 갔다가 동 연무장기를
최근에 팔렸던 거 어 3억원을 팔렸던
거를 좀 볼 거예요. 그래서이 건물이
원래 작년에 한 1, 2년도 안
됐는데 한 245억 원을 샀다가
리모델링을 한 다음에 아직 실거래
찍히진 않았지만 한 300억 중반에
매각 됐다라는 어 얘기가 좀
있습니다. 그래서 어떻게 보면 동
연무장에 3억을 찍은게 이게
최초거든요. 가격이 정말 빨리 오르고
있습니다. 그래서서 연무장길은 아마
더 비쌀 것 같아요. 지금 동
연무장도 4억이나 아니면 5억 정도의
매물이 나오고 있어요. 매물도 많이
없을 뿐더러 그래서 일단 동연무장길에
최근에 팔렸던 거 어 보러 갈
겁니다. 진짜 빨리 변하는 거
같아요. 그래서 동 연무장길에도
임대도 되게 잘 들어와요. 임대료
수준도 되게 높습니다. 저희가서
연무장길에 임대 맞친게 하나 있는데
그게 이제 연면적 한 100평 정도
되는데 월세가 거의 1억이에요. 거의
명동 가격입니다. 임대 평단가로 거의
100만 원 정도인데 사실 명동의
돼지 평단가가 뭐 7억 8억 막
최고가에 팔린 거 10억까지도
팔렸잖아요. 네. 그래서 그런 걸
비추어 볼 때 임대료가 많이
올라가거나이 정도 수준을 유지한다라고
하면 앞으로 더 비싸게 팔린 사례들도
많이 생겨나지 않을까 이렇게
생각합니다. 그래서 일단 성수동의 또
장점이라고 하면 땅들이 되게 커요.
네. 땅들이 되게 커 가지고 기업들이
여기 들어와서 뭐 팝업 스토어라든지
여기 임차기가 되게 좋거든요. 땅이
커 가지고. 성수동은 예전에 이제 다
공장 지대였고 땅 평수가 큰 그런
공장들이 많아서 기업들이 되게
들어오기에 좋은 조건을 가지고 있는
거 같습니다. 그래서 여기 기준으로
여기 지금 프라다 있는 쪽 기준으로
좌측이 서무장 여기가 원래 제일
좋았었고 그리고 우측이 이제
동무장길이에요. 그래서 일단 동무장길
쪽으로 갈게요. 와 진짜 사람 여기
진짜 많아졌어요. 진짜 많아졌습니다.
진짜 아무도 없었거든요. 여기까지
지금 확장이 되면서 어 사람들이 되게
많아졌습니다. 와, 진짜 너무 많다.
그리 외국인들이 많아요. 외국인들이
많고 저희도 여기서 팝업 스토어를 해
봤지만 외국인들 비율이 제가 봤을 때
과반수 이상입니다. 거의 한 6,
70% 그 이상 되는 거 같아요.
그래서 그 정도로 외국인이 많습니다.
그리고 대체적으로 여성분들이 좀 많고
와 여기까지 저기까지 이러다가
자양동까지 이런 생각을 할 수도
있지만 사람들이 대로변은 진짜 안
건너갑니다. 요거예요. 요거 에이스가
산 겁니다. 빨간 건물. 와,
여기까지는 진짜 또 많이 안 하는데
또 많이 오네요. 여기까지. 저는
요즘에 빌딩 뭐 어디 투자하면
좋아요. 막 물어보면 외국인들이 많이
오는 곳 그리고 부자들이 많이 사는
곳을 많이 좀 추천하긴 하거든요.
성수역 기준으로 남쪽이 지금 되게
좋은 상태고 그리고 북성수 그러니까
이제 성수역 기준으로 북쪽을 이제
북성수라고 하는데 거기도 이제
덩달아서 가격이 좀 오르고 있긴 한데
가격이 일단 폭발 쪽으로 오르는 곳은
여기 남쪽이에요. 그리고 아까
말씀드렸다시피 같은 성수기도 하지만
여기 대로변을 넘어서 그렇게 많이
가진 않습니다. 그래서 연무장길
이쪽으로가 보겠습니다. 보시면은 다
외국인이에요. 아, 여기도 사람이
많네요. 아마 가격 상승률로 봤을
때는 단기간의 성수동이 최고지 않나
싶습니다. 네. 서울시에서 서울시가
아니라 전국 전국부에서 이건 지금서
연무장길은 거의 뭐 명동 수준인데
그리고 저희가 이제 팝업 스토어 해
봤잖아요. 주말에가 진짜 많습니다.
토요일 특히 금요일도 많고 저기 가기
무섭지 그죠? 일단가 보겠습니다.
일단 고하겠습니다. 여기 이쪽으로
한번가 보시죠. 뭔가 심상치 않아요.
큰일 났네. 사람 진짜 많습니다.
계속 지금 엑셀에 발을 댔다
브레이크를 댔다가 발을 댔다가
브레이크 됐다가 지금 와 이거 큰일
났다. 실히서 연무장이 더 많긴
해요. 사람은 이게 뭔가 차 없는
거리를 만들어야 될 것 같아요. 이거
팝업 스토어도 되게 많고 여기
현수막다는 것도 진짜 보통 한 2주
3주 이렇게 해서 다는데 그것도 막
몇 천만 원 돼요. 그래서 그 정도로
되게 들어갈 것이 없고 진짜 광고
달만한 것들이 없어서 요겁니다. 요게
이제 팔렸었고 그때 이제 3억 찍어
가지고 막 이렇게 이슈 많이 됐었죠.
돼지가 30평대인데 110억 정도의
매각이 됐습니다. 근데 뭐 지금도
이렇게 생각해 보면 잘 산 거
같아요. 그니까 여기 뭐 임대료
수준이 워낙 높아 가지고 여기 또
코너땅이거든요. 그래서 100만
원이라고 가정하면 옆면적이 정확히 몇
평인지 모르겠지만 거의 1억 가까이
되지 않을까요? 1억까진 안 가더라도
뭐 한 7천 뭐이 정도 되지 않을까?
7 8천 예상입니다. 네. 저기
앞에까지도 괜찮아요. 일단은 여기가
메인이고 가격이 제일 많이 오르는데
저기 그 뚝섬역 거기 밑에도
괜찮아요. 뭐요 정도까진 아니지만
그래도 가격도 많이 오르고 임대료
수준도 되게 높습니다. 그래서 일단은
성수역 기준으로 남쪽은 괜찮은 상황
같아요. 그리고 지금 아뜰리길 쪽으로
가고 있고 일단은 이쪽 변 그니까
북성수랑 여기 연무장길 쪽은 중공업
지역이거든요. 근데 지금 저기
아뜰리의 길 쪽은 중공업 지역이
아니에요. 업무를 그렇게 높게 짓지도
못하고 그런 부분 때문에 여기보다
상대적으로 좀 저렴하긴 합니다.
그리고 여기랑 분위기는 조금 다른 거
같아요. 그래서 거기는 뭐 공장이
많이 있다기보다는 원래 거긴 좀 주거
지역이었거든요. 그래서 이렇게 주거
시설 건물을 리모델링해서 이렇게 쓰는
건물들이 많습니다. 그래서 지금
연모장끼리랑은 조금 다른 느낌이긴
해요. 근데 여기도 되게 비싸게
팔려요. 막 1억 초반 중반에도
거래가 돼서. 그리고 유동 인구는 뭐
연무장길 정도는 아닌 거 같아요. 또
여기 느낌 좋아하시는 분들도 있고
한번 들어가 볼게요. 그래서 여기
보시면은 연무장기랑 좀 느낌 많이
달라요. 다 이제 이렇게 상가주택
건물이거나 아니면 이런 주거 건물들을
다 이렇게 리모델링 해 가지고 쓰고
있습니다. 저는 개인적으로는 뭐 성수
투자한다 그러면 뭐 이쪽 편도
아무래도 상대적으로 좀 저렴하니까
여기도 괜찮은데 일단은 최대한 저기
그 성수역 남쪽 연무장길 근처를 보는
거를 좀 추천을 합니다. 그리고 또
많은 분들이 얘기하는게 뱀의 머리가
났냐, 뭐 용의 꼬리가 맞냐 뭐 이런
얘기를 많이 하는데 저 개인적인
생각에는 용의 꼬리가 났습니다.
황금성에서도 차이가 많이 나고 앞으로
상권도 좀 공원 근처, 도상공원
근처, 서울숲 근처 이런 데가 되게
더 각강을 받을 거 같아요. 일단은
좀 급으로 좀 돌아봤는데 어떠셨나요?
그래서 성수동에 많이 투자한다라고
하면 여기 성수역 뚝섬역 기준으로
남쪽을 일단 유심히 보시면 좋을 거
같고 그리고 이제 더 나아가서는
북성수라든지 아들리의길까지 검토하시면
좋을 거 같아요. 여러분들 만약에
가봤으면 좋겠다라는 곳을 댓글을 좀
남겨 주시면 제가 추가적으로 또
준비를 해서 다음번 임장 그 장소로
정하도록 하겠습니다. 그래서 오늘
영상은 여기까지 하고요. 여러분들
다음에 뵙도록 하겠습니다.
감사합니다.
[음악]